good evening America good morning
Indonesia aha
I'm Greg Alba I am John one of the
things that led this channel to growing
was when we covered the raid films back
in the day and supposedly according to
many a comments Iko Weis the best part
of mile 22 the best part of the for such
a great cameo i think the raid team is
here other than you know
gareth evidence yep that's the one he's
doing the apostle for Netflix instead I
can't wait to get into this let's just
roll yeah how would you do me I don't
wanna go in hell yeah landing do so no
success Okumura I like that power we
decided to Lemuria
[Music]
sadly the funkadilly evaluating panda
[Music]
okay magic this boy oh damn save the
little girl
penguins kind of I don't have anything
but okay you see the time
so it kind of looks like
yeah
day
man I am so happy this is covenant
efflux to say weekend daredevil comes
out dad's we're gonna have this one bone
crunching it is so much intensely
realistic violence you just know that
this is trailer eight even scratching
the surface of what's gonna come from
these guys no look I got a confession to
make I never actually watched head shot
but what I did deal with someone one day
was I watched all the fight scenes
Rashad
I know there's probably said some people
that that's all I did but man those are
some epic ass fight scenes in that movie
- like the right people behind this a
director of head shot doing this and
equalizes it looks like he's the villain
in this yeah which is cool you know
minutes to see him play a different type
of role as a silly American I can never
tell when someone does a bad job if it's
a foreign language film simply because I
don't speak the language so for all I
know they're probably doing a great job
or a terrible job shut your mouth people
say can't they follow me on macchiato
off the dome I feel like he's gonna be a
good villain but they premiered this
well I don't know there's really
premiered it but they played it at TIFF
and this was one of the biggest talks at
if every once in a while he'd be getting
invited to like a screening of a Netflix
film to be at a theater never gone
iroh's catch on Netflix but this was
playing you just know the fight scenes
are not gonna be really shown here in
the trailer but when they're in the
movie they're gonna be epic if you guys
have seen the raid films if you've seen
any of the fight scenes from headshot
you will know this movie is gonna be
frickin epic and you get like a little
hints at it oh yeah if you're watching
this on a big screen or really even a
small screen I got imagine that you're
going to be cringing and you're
squirming and feeling phantom pain for
all the different limbs that are being
broken and sliced apart and you pointed
out that over the head shot where the
crowds kind of piling you ads people
charged in each other because I remember
when like people freaked out about that
in the headshot trailer - doing this
similar shot right there yeah yeah yeah
I feel like the style is just super
kinetic and hyper bone-crunching because
they really find ways of playing up just
how hard all the impacts are and how
brutal yeah yeah bone breaks and knife
slices are and everything and like even
those little walk tough GoPro shots like
on the side of a gun just to make
everything live that much more intense
I mean what's cool about what these guys
do with their movies is that they tell I
mean the raid 2 gets rather complex and
the way the plot unfolds like a crime it
yeah you gotta pay attention
it's like the depart is that film yeah
the first raid even the plot of headshot
and even the setup of the raid - there
are fairly simple plots to latch on to
that makes the action easier to get like
emotionally invested in rather than
getting complex our having no story they
still deliver on having good character
and they deliver on this emotional
intensity and having visceral action you
know like the people being advertised
here joe taslim and eco elias but if you
really pay attention to trailer those
fights you know they are there you know
yeah fight scenes were just like two
chicks going at it and everything yeah
this looks like it's gonna be one epic
ass film and also some cool
cinematography I like any fight scenes
that are like in clubs with neon colors
and everything cool soundtrack to go
yeah I mean these trailers always make
it look like this movies is gonna be two
straight hours of action yeah you know
with like maybe a couple talks seen some
I am curious about what the overall you
know tone and feel of the story is gonna
be like especially if we are correct and
it equalizes the villain of this yeah
because it's an interesting turn you
know and I don't really remember the
names of a lot of like the other actors
from from these films but I'm pretty
sure we saw some other familiar faces as
well throughout this trailer and in some
ways it kind of feels like a like a
spiritual successor is the proper term I
think you would use for it's just
something like the raid or yeah I would
love it if it was like hidden sequel
like oh this is where his character
would be crossed over after everything
he's been through yeah absolutely
immersed in doesn't know which one
there's also gonna be a little girl you
know it's always an intriguing action
plot when it's like all the centers
around a child of some kind like I said
it's you know like the plots are very
simple than we've seen them done before
yeah yeah yeah and I mean that's bad job
besides I got to protect little girl and
then now he's on this mission to be a
better person
yeah and now it's just about how well do
we roll that wheel usually pretty well
it is there are a lot of badassery which
is gonna deliver on so and there's
probably gonna be like at least one very
inventive
fight where you're like
like you know like the baseball girl
thing I'll probably do something like
that man I think they always these guys
always deliver on their finale fight too
I think that's like a big thing they do
understand build up they know that you
know you gotta have a good introductory
fight you gotta have some good stuff in
between tuitions but usually their final
fight they go all out like those are
long fight scenes the final ones
especially those go on for a while so
yeah I know this is gonna give me
everything I want I just know yeah
anyway guys before we wrap this up I
want to give a patron of the day shout
out to a man named JT the man from
Hawaii JT and I have been talking a
little bit here on Twitter as of late
and this guy's losing a lot of faith in
Fox with them pushing the release date
schedules of all these things doesn't
have faith in Dark Phoenix doesn't have
faith in New Mutants and JT I got to
tell you man you need to get your head
in a more positive direction mm you're
just gonna bring it on yourself you know
the movies are gonna turn out bad how
are you helping these guys make better
movies if you are not willing to put
more positive energy if you keep putting
negative energy out there it's going to
be a bad movie it's it's on you it's
your responsibility okay like the fate
of Hollywood rests in your hands or your
head anyway you don't know the effect
that you have on this industry buddy you
know what how we run our channel lets JT
gonna think it's JT gonna like this
video is JT gonna be happy how do you
think the people of Fox think do you
think they're going with screen junkies
saying what's Collider videos saying
what's red letter media gonna say no
they [ __ ] about those guys they're going
what is that Japanese guy who lives in
Hawaii gonna say mmhmm about this girl
from Game of Thrones being in our horror
x-men movie I blame you for every
problem YouTube has ever had yeah thanks
for those yellow dollar bill signs
yeah thanks dick jeepers Christ you're a
great man JT good man JT you guys can
subscribe with the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us out
on patreon
show reactions Q&A is love to have you
come up a project today
you